[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance I appeal to the intelligence
agencies and the governments of what is
left of the free world to them as
entities entireties as bureaucracies
making official decisions and to the
individuals who make decisions of
conscience to GCHQ and mi6 in the UK to
the BND in Germany the DGSE in France
the asis in Australia and even to the
GRU in Russia where they must already be
profoundly aware that they have not
merely helped put an amoral cynic in
power here but an uncontrollable one
whose madness is genuine and whose
usefulness even to them is at an end to
all of them and to the world's
journalists I make this plea we the
citizens of the United States of America
are the victims of a coup we need your
leaks your information your intelligence
your recordings your videos your
conscience the civilian government and
the military of the United States are no
longer in the hands of the people nor in
the control of any responsible
individuals on whom you can rely the
first step towards compromising our FBI
occurred Tuesday with the unilateral
firing of its director by the president
prompted by the Attorney General both of
whom are or were at least in theory
possibly to be under investigation by
the FBI as led by that director they
fired our CIA is run by one of that
president's political appointees the
first National Security Advisor was
fired and may have been a Russian stooge
the second National Security Advisor has
reportedly been yelled at by the
president because he had had the
temerity to disagree with him our State
Department is in the hands of useless
amateurs our United Nations mission is
bereft of power and uninformed and the
White House is run by a cabal of an
amoral family syndicate that has spent
its first three months slapping a dollar
sign on anything that stood still long
enough a cabal with at its head a man
with seemingly no interest in our laws
in our rights in our Constitution and
with a brain that appears to not work
properly through our own negligence the
resentments and stupidities of millions
of us and the boundless greed of our
elite class our democracy has all but
slipped away from us it hangs today by a
thread
and those who could protect it and
restore it and fight for it even at this
late date the Republican politicians
whose voices today could force Trump out
of office tomorrow
they are almost silent owned by special
interests and silenced by a power that
exceeds even whatever dedication to
freedom they once had all but a few of
them fall back into platitudes about the
leader of the country firing the head of
the FBI and precipitating a
constitutional crisis in order to shut
down the investigation of his possible
high crimes and misdemeanors our
majority party impotently rings its
hands about timing and how troubled they
are and then they go back to calculating
how they will most easily get reelected
with whose money by whose instructions
we the citizens of the United States of
America are victims of a coup for months
we have heard that your organization's
have damning evidence against Donald
John Trump whatever evidence you may
have you cannot conceal it any longer
whatever we in this country are to you
now wherever you are now you know that
this nation has been a savior to you at
some point in the past and that our
stability and our freedom and a
government controlling this country that
is at least sane is your surest
guarantee of a prosperous future indeed
perhaps your surest guarantee of any
future at all
now we need your help whatever there is
on Trump reveal it issue it officially
if you can leak it if you cannot if your
directors and your governments want you
to wait look to the last days here and
ask yourselves plum your conscience --is
if there is any time left to wait give
it to a reporter give it to an American
friend put it on the Internet leave it
outside somebody's back door there is no
time left for protocols and estimations
of long-term impacts and tradecraft a
dictator in training has betrayed our
Constitution and nevertheless survived
two nights in office
the dictatorship he may want the
dictatorship he may feel as the natural
extension of his past life the
dictatorship he may believe he has
earned has gone in this week from
crawling to taking its first few
tentative steps what you have we need
and we need it now enter the
intelligence community of this country
your patriotic duty is clear in many
respects in the months since the
election you have provided your greatest
service in our history a democracy that
has lost its political way staggers down
the street like a drunk and lurches
towards the gutter yet you have walked a
virtually bipartisan straight line and
you have followed your rules and you
have followed the rules of the civilians
and yet the evildoers still exist
regardless the greatest threat to the
freedoms of this nation that this nation
has ever faced the Trump administration
the Trump Hunta is playing by no rules
they just offed the FBI director and let
him find out about it by reading a TV
news crawl in the back of the room in
which he was addressing his Los Angeles
office they have no rules for now the
rest of us who only want our democracy
back we can have no rules either we will
take the risk of reestablishing the
rules later on what you in the FBI in
the CIA in the Justice Department have
on Trump we also need now because by
tomorrow it may disappear and your
ability to do anything with it may
disappear as well some of us here on the
outside have tried the best we could to
prevent this day others less so right
now it doesn't matter who did much when
you and the FBI CIA the other
intelligence agencies the Justice
Department you must be the Patriots now
you and the five eyes in the psia and
Japan in the outfits around the world to
secret to have their names known to us
you must become for the moment Americans
we need what you have and we need it now
and we need it made public it is more
than just
fate of this sloppy but well-meaning
country that is at risk for all of our
faults for good or bad we cannot be left
as a fascist rogue state and an enemy of
freedom and international comity the
fate of all freedoms may rest in your
hands
and your willingness to not merely hint
but show what you know if we go under
you are next the freedom you save will
be your own resist peace